Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning
podcast for Monday,
October 29th,
2012 how's it going? How are you?
You know, I said a really weird,
really weird fucking thought.
As I was sitting down here
getting ready to do this podcast,
looking at my new mixer, I had
to buy a new mixer. By the way.
There was the one bad thing that happened
to me when I went to Australia was, uh,
you know, had this piece of shit mixer
that I brought that was like, you know,
99 bucks and I plugged it into the wall
and there was some sort of surge in the
fucking thing died as I told you
last week. So I finally had to, uh,
had to go out and buy a new one.
Does it sound any different?
I don't know why I bought one that was
cost me twice as much money to do the
exact same fucking podcast that nobody
ever bitched about other than the fact
that they say it's never out on Monday
morning despite the fact they explain
every fucking week that it's my Monday
morning. I do it on Monday morning. Okay.
It's not about you. It's about me. This
is all about me. You understand me?
Well, um, anyway,
has had this really fucked up thought
that I've been doing this podcast since
like June or July of 2007 every,
basically every Monday. I remember one
year, it took two weeks off for Christmas.
That was nice. Back before this
became a corporate entity. Um,
I, uh, I just realized
I got, I got, you know,
I keep forgetting the hype,
our new podcast page, the
a all things comedy page.
Why don't you fucking go to that every
once in a while? Oh, I'm the worst.
Why do I drink before I do these things?
Whenever I do this,
it never fucking goes, well, let's stay
on track, Bill. Stay on track. Okay.
You're freckled cunt. All right, here
we go. So I had this thought, you know,
I basically let me doing this podcast
every Monday since June or July of 2007.
Right?
Every fucking Monday on
basically documenting every
Monday of my fucking life,
give or take. Sometimes a Tuesday
is Sunday, whatever. All right.
Don't split hairs with me. I'm not in the
fucking mood. And I was just wondering,
you know, when is going to be
the last Monday of my life?
One of these is going to be the,
it's going to be the last Monday.
How far away is that?
Monday you start thinking about
like the ever even think of,
but just about like Diane, you
know, I know it's a Monday.
You don't need to hear this will fuck you.
I'm thinking about it.
Okay.
I mean hopefully it's going to be a long
ways off, but what if I died tragically,
you know, one of those fucking,
what's a good tragic death, you know,
how'd he get you replaced
the light over the garage?
Yeah,
it's been out for like the last two
weeks and I get out of the car and I just
hear things. I don't know what
it is. I don't know. Leaves,
I dunno if it's a bird or like a,
some sort of bugs are right.
I'll fucking change it.
You don't have to yell.
Right. And then you go out there after
you had a couple of beers, right.
You go up where on that fucking step
ladder that's supposed to be for your
mother in law so she can get up there
and get her fucking favorite ball,
the Pura God damn fucking or
uh, cheerio's into, right.
You grabbed that one instead instead
of dragging out the silver one because
you're fucking lazy and he'd take that
little step ladder out and you get all
the way up to the top and it's only
three steps and you can't quite reach it.
Right. See fucking get on
your little tippy toes. Right.
And you start reaching up for the fucker.
All of a sudden you hear that rattling.
You look like dad, you pull a nerve
in your neck and there you go.
Fucking reverse lawn,
dark fucking inverted like that plane.
And that Denzel movie where he's like,
I'm sorry I was drunk and my
Afro wasn't picked out correctly,
but did I or did I not land
the fucking plane safely?
That's what it's going to be.
90 minutes of that,
90 minutes of that.
All right.
Yes, but she would drunk. Yeah, but he's
still alive. Well that's not the point.
Yeah, it is. Go Fuck Yourself.
Did you know fucking mad?
I would be if I landed a plane,
shit faced and somebody gave
me a rough time about it. Well,
why were you drunk?
I don't know cause it's fucking boring
cause that's where I take off.
I just throw it on fucking autopilot and
then I'm basically just sitting in this
fucking uncomfortable,
lazy boy that I cannot get out
of for the next four to six hours
till I talked to some other Douche
bag. Okay. I flew in fucking, I flew,
I had fucking combat missions.
I'm used to getting shot at and now
I'm doing this driving a fucking bus.
It's not going to drink.
Okay.
When it came down to it,
that motherfucker was upside down and
I still landed it and you'll giving me
shit. Do you know much
fucking money? I saved you,
right?
Isn't that what's going to be? That'd
be an owl. That's if I wrote that movie,
that's what it would be.
It would be the first 10 minutes
is him getting shit faced. Right.
The next fucking five to seven
minutes is all the holy fuck.
We're upside down a bunch of fat cows
hanging from their fucking seat belts is
the hero. The movies such a bad ass.
His hat doesn't even come off right,
and he's just slurring.
I got it, I got it right.
And everybody's screaming like
a bunch of bitches. Any of that.
I go fuck yourselves. Right? And then he
lands it. And when he lands and everybody,
high fives, a man, when he's
standing there going, hey,
thank you for flying fucking twa or
whatever. He takes a little flask out,
takes another hit,
slapped some fucking stewardess on her
ass and he gets off the plane and then he
falls down the stairs, right? That's the
left. That's the left turn for the comedy.
And then everybody starts
breaking his fucking balls.
That'll be the next two pages. It's what?
What are we up to now? Page 19 all right,
so from page 19 to page 120 is going to
be him screaming at all the fucking pee
on instead of yelling at him
for being drunk. You know,
would you rather have me be stoned,
sober and actually contemplate
my own fucking mortality?
You know, I would have ended
up in the fucking Goddamn Lake.
You know something.
You always like believe the movie and
then Hollywood always has to Hollywood it
up.
Did he really have to be completely upside
down like he was in the fucking blue
angels? I mean, I guess those planes,
they can actually do that shit,
but give me a fucking break.
Okay.
Okay. Do you know how much work
that's going to be for the fucking,
the props people where every fucking take,
they got a fucking clean coffee
it trail mix off the ceiling
of this fucking plane,
this fake half a fucking play it out.
Gives a shit.
Let's plow ahead. At least you know we
actually were coming along way though.
I feel that could affect that
Denzel was a pilot and it,
there's no racial issue there. It's
just that he's a drunk. That's great.
That's actually a good thing
and I'm not even being funny.
Like that's actually a good thing because
the second I saw it I was expecting
like my old joke, you know, whether
it was good, be some like, all right,
fine with that son.
Of a bitch.
I thought it was going to be one
of those movies and it wasn't.
It was just like he did a great thing,
but he was drunk. Now what do we do bill?
We've seen trailer. How long are
you going to milk it? We got it.
You got to fill a fucking hour.
How about changing the topic?
Once every 19 minutes. Alright, fine.
All right,
let's get back to talking to my about
my death or is my fun or is this podcast
just going to go on way
longer than it should?
Way past the time that it's fucking
relevant and fuck all you can to send me
emails that said stop being relevant
the day I started doing it. All right.
Could go on for the easy jokes.
Step up your game if you're going to be
fucking mean. Let's try to be creative.
You know where I'm at? Um, at at
Paul Versey, that's my Twitter handle
anyways. Yeah. What if I go way
too long and I'm like 87 years old,
like approach approaching
like that Bob Hope Age,
right? Sitting here wheezing, you
know, with some 22 year old girl,
works over the varicose veins in my
fucking legs so I can just keep podcasting
or I could go out classy.
I could go out at about 59 right?
And 15 fucking years I could go out like
Johnny Carson actually if I went left
at 59, I go out like Jay Leno and then
I would give to my podcast to some other
redheaded guy and then
come back and take it.
So I'll go out like Carson at about 65
66 and that's how I'm going to do it.
I would wear a Tuxedo and I'm
gonna sit here quietly and uh,
I'll pay the greatest hits of the podcast
from the previous week cause I'm too
fucking lazy. There's no fucker web
going through. What would that be?
20 years of a podcast. It
ain't happening. All right.
So do you guys just get
that out of your heads?
There will be no farewell
show on this podcast,
this podcast. I've started like fucking
four times, cause I swear to God,
I'm still buzzing a little bit so I can't
even remember what the Hell I talked
about. Um, I don't know.
Did I talk about football yet? Have I
talked about it? I don't give a shit.
They didn't talk about, I talked about the
Patriots. Right? Did I? It gives a fuck.
You know what,
I'm just going to go forward and if I
feel like I already talked about it then,
then that's just what it's going to be.
You're like that.
I got a little philosophical there. I've
got a little hippy on you, didn't I? Um,
I didn't really talk about it last
week, by the way. Uh, I can't even,
I started to touch on it, but I was
a little out of sorts because my, uh,
I didn't have my mix up on my
fucking headphones last week,
so I was just really just felt
weird to just sit there, be talking
to a goddamn laptop top us,
speaking of which I want to
do that ted.com just look
up robots and try to find
the one where the, with this,
this, this lady is sitting there,
she's fucking talking about,
you know,
having robots around the house.
Okay.
You know what I mean? It is the
stupidest thing. Okay. First of all,
she's whoring it up for no
particular reason in the beginning.
I don't know why she's wearing
like these hooker boots.
She sitting there talking about robots
to a bunch of Egghead nerds and she's
still got a horror it up.
It's like,
can't you just stand on the merit of
the fucking speech that you wrote?
Do you really got to get
people's Dicks half full?
Just so they'll keep listening to you?
How fucking insecure are you?
You're talking about robots in the house.
Okay.
Walking down the hallway.
What's up?
Fucking high five and a
God damn robot that right.
And it's not like it's a movie.
It's fucking real.
That's not compelling enough of a subject.
You can't hold the audience's interest.
You still have to put on
your street walker boots.
It's weird. She has on street walker
boots, but she has on a modest skirt.
It comes down a little maybe cause
the boots go up so fucking high.
You know what I mean? I mean there
isn't that basically the rule,
if you're going to wear the
fucking thigh high boots,
you basically have to
have on a mini skirt.
Okay.
Um, by the way, how great, how
our holidays Halloween become?
It's just the fucking greatest thing ever.
You know what I mean?
It's just girls just go
out dress like horse.
Even girls who aren't horse dress like
whores is fucking great, you know?
Phenomenal.
I took me to lunch and there was some
girls standing there in basically,
who's kidding?
Who was something David Lee Roth would
a warrant except it was on a woman,
so it was fucking great.
It was just black and white.
Striped,
basically spandex suit and then she was
standing there with these grain pumps on
and then some sort of ears and
evidently that was a costume.
I don't know what it was. I'll tell you,
I don't know what it was, but I locked it.
Shit. Um, you know, I was
sitting there the other night,
last night actually,
he says through the cloud of alcohol and
I was on this sportsmans channel and I
was watching rednecks shooting wild pigs.
Okay.
From a helicopter. This was a
sport. I mean, who's kidding, who?
It's a fucking skill.
The pigs are running,
the helicopter is moving,
but they fly the helicopter,
they try to fly as close to
the same speed as the pig.
And it's just such a fucking joke.
After awhile dead.
It's just like you just start rooting
for the pigs. Stupid ass fucking pig.
Just stay under the trees.
He can't see you.
And they just fucking shoot
one God damn pig after another.
And I'm sitting there going like,
Jesus Christ to fucking pigs.
He's gotta be 600 pounds worth the meat.
You know,
kind of fucking barbecue.
You haven't stopped shooting
these God damn wild boars,
right. And they keep
cutting to the guy go, well,
what are the difficulties when you're,
uh,
when you are in a helicopter trying to
hew to peg is when we try and do a lead
them how far you're supposed to lead them.
It's basically the scene from full
metal jacket. Yes sir. Yes sir.
Get some except it's pigs rather
than children in Vietnam and women,
you know. So anyways, so they cut to the
whole thing like it's fucking hilarious.
The Guy who is teaching you how to do
it is some retired special forces guy.
He had this Australian accent and I'm
just thinking of all the fucking shit that
this guy's done.
Okay.
You know what I mean? It's almost like
seeing like a retired athlete who,
you know it like the ground round,
who like won a super bowl.
Now he is in the fucking corner booth
sitting there eating fish and chips.
You know what I'm saying?
And literally the hottest girl in the
place can walk over and just show him his
clamp, her clam, and he's not
even going to fucking bat an eye.
You know why? Because he
walked on the moon. It's over.
He's been to outer space does,
you can't get the guy's
fucking heart rate going again.
So I'm fucking sitting there looking
at the special forces guy just go,
and this is, this is, this is the end.
You know, you're sneaking around
Saddam's fucking Cabana, snapping necks,
you know,
dressed like Tom Cruise at the beginning
of fucking mission impossible doing all
that shit I want. It's over
honorable discharge. Where are you?
You're in the middle of fucking
Texas teaching rednecks,
how to shoot fucking pigs
from a helicopter. And the
guys just sit and they go,
yeah, you know, uh, you know, got to
leave him that far. Just basically,
if you aim just a little in front of their
nose with how fast the helicopters go
on,
you're going to get a body shot.
And with the caliber of
bullet that you're shooting,
it's going to be a kill
shot. Ah, Jesus Christ.
I got to get a divorce. Um, so anyways,
this is the great thing.
So they cut to the fucking guy whose ranch
they're basically hunting on and he's
sitting down,
cause I'm sitting there going,
why are they killing
all these God damn pigs?
And this fucking guy on the ranch
is just sitting there going like,
he's like, oh, they layer multiplied.
Uh, it's, they're, they're,
they ate all the grass in the front yard.
They ate the grass in the backyard.
I mean, they're, they're a
plague. Wait, we have to,
we have to do this viral moving
400 pigs from the population.
It's actually a good thing that
he kept calling him a plague.
They're a plague.
Wild pigs are a fucking plague.
Okay.
You know, that's the one thing, like,
I'm fascinated with stereotypical
conservative and liberal thought.
You know, people just sort of
think one way all the fucking time.
Like the genius of Conservative thought
is it holds people responsible for their
actions. You know what I mean?
You don't get to be like, well,
that's because my mom left when
I was at kick out. Fuck yourself.
Get stabbed someone, you're going
to jail, you can't. All right.
That's when it totally makes sense.
Right?
But those guys like that,
the thing about them is they have a
complete inability to ever step outside
themselves and see it from
another perspective. Okay.
If 400 fucking
okay,
wild boar on your property or a plague,
what are 7 billion human beings?
What are we classified as?
I don't understand what you mean.
God said go forth and multiply.
Go out and take a shit in the
fucking ocean. I'm an that. Now.
What did he put all this here for us?
Like that fucking thought.
You know, like no matter what
you do, you're fucking right.
You just see shit.
They just looking out their own fucking
heads would be one thing. If he said,
listen, I get it. They got
a right to be here too,
but I make my living off my fucking
ranch and I can't have these fat cats
running around eating everything that
I'm growing. Then I'd be like, all right,
I see that. But to call them
a fucking plague, you know?
Does that make any sense to you guys?
Did I add?
And I actually say it in a way that
made sense after booze and all day,
once cleos asleep
on the floor.
Anyways,
let's get to some advertising
here for this week. Uh,
Jesus and I talk too fucking long.
I got to answer the phone.
I got to enter the password.
Who the hell told me to do this?
You've got to make sure your
computer's locked down for what?
Yeah,
like I have the codes to
launch the fucking missiles.
I was trying to say launch the missile,
Sarah. Um, stamps.com everybody. Hey,
do you like going to the post
office? Well, keep going buddy.
Cause that part of my life is over
because I have stamps.com everyone.
I have the post office in my house.
What do you mean literally?
Not Literally stupid.
I mean I have all the components I need
that I never have to go to the post
office unless I choose c now I'm in the
driver's seat a week ago or whenever the
hell I started doing this a year ago.
Whenever the hell it was.
Okay.
It wasn't my choice. I had to go down
there. They had me by the short hairs.
Now I got dumb. Now I don't
need them. I broke up with them.
They're calling me wanting to get back
together. Okay. Ain't happening. Why?
Because with stamps.com,
you can buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer
whenever you need it. 24, seven or
you can sponge off your roommates.
I imagined probably get
annoying after awhile.
I'm no more wasting time with the
post office. What a hassle. Um,
it's written right there in
the copy. What a hassle. Oh,
how old was the person who wrote this?
What a hassle man.
The pigs came down were
hassling us at the protest, man.
No need to lease an expensive posts.
A postage meter.
stamps.com offers more features then a
meter@afractionofthepriceplusstamps.com
customers receive special
discounts on mailing and shipping.
You can't even get at the post office.
I use stamps.com to send all of my DVDs,
do the wonderful places that I perform at.
Uh, right now you want a special offer?
Use My last name,
bur bur are no risk trial plus $110 bonus
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. All right? They just giving
you 55 bucks. Basically. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our, that's stamps.com
enter [inaudible]. All right,
back to the podcast here. Um, so anyways,
as I was mentioning, uh, traveling
to Australia, I can't remember,
did I already talk about this?
That's the theme of this.
Did I or did I already say this?
Stop me if I've repeated this. Um,
if you never traveled
outside of the country,
I'm talking to Americans here
and stop rolling your eyes.
You can't see fucking Europeans.
All right? Goddamn assholes.
You trip over a fucking broom stick.
You fall into another country over there.
Okay.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Literally you can from England,
there's like people who can swim to
France. That's how fucking close it is.
Literally swim to France before the
sharks get them. It doesn't make any,
but they can
do it.
That's how close it is.
It's like when the Bruins used
to play the fucking whalers,
you could decide at five o'clock
you want to go to the game,
fucking jump on the mass
pike and you would get out,
make a left and you were there.
Um,
Australia is a great one to start
with. It really is. First of all,
their customers is great. It was
fucking awesome. They just say, hey,
how's it go and get in there yet coop,
they toss your hair,
none of that nine 11 shit. Slap your on
your ass and you're fucking in there.
You're in the country.
Then everybody speaks English
already and if you're from Boston,
it's going to sound familiar because
they basically have a Boston accent.
They just stretch it out a
little bit more. We say beer,
they say [inaudible] we say blockbuster.
They say blockbuster,
it's terrible accent. Go Fuck Yourself.
It's basically what it is. All right.
The good people,
they're fun people and they like to
booze and they don't bring up our foreign
policy. I don't know why, but
they don't. So there you go.
There's my ringing
endorsement for Australia. Um,
oh, you know what he did when I get
on the way back, I actually, uh,
you know that duty free shit,
I don't even get it.
Everybody goes fucking nuts when they
go in there and they got like chocolate
bars the size of a fucking
log you'd thrown in a fire
that Toblerone they live.
It was the size of a fucking pillow
and not one of those ones that you just
throw on a fucking sofa to dress it up,
but you couldn't put your head on it.
It's useless actually. Makes you hurt
your neck even more. Not One of those,
I mean one of those, I'm going to
bed, right. Full-Size fucking pillow.
All right guys.
I'm having a different way.
They've got to fucking explain it
to you all made out of chocolate,
right? They got, they got, I took a
picture of it. They had a fucking,
it was Johnny Walker blue
or Johnny Walker black.
This thing,
it was decided.
You ever see those gas cans they use
in racing like Nascar where they just
fucking tip that thing up?
It was like the size of that.
I literally put my fucking
ghost white hand next to it,
just to give you a little
bit of perspective how big
it was. And it was like,
I dunno. I Dunno. It was like,
and like 200 bucks. I can't even,
I can't tell if it's a deal or not because
everything is gigantic and it's still
costs a couple hundred bucks.
So I'm walking through there and
it's all kinds of fucking Cologne,
like 10 years worth of Cologne,
perfumes, all kinds of booze.
So I finally say to this law,
okay,
I go, Hey, do you got any? You got any
cigars? And she's like, yeah we do.
You gotta go in here.
So I walked through this whole fucking
little maze to this back room and I walk
in and I go, you got any Cubans? You got
some Cuban cigars? And they're like, yeah,
we don't have a problem with Fidel Castro.
That's fucking you guys. All right.
So I say,
cool.
So I go and I buy a box of fucking
25 of them and it's cool, man.
They got like the actual,
like I bought Cuban cigars but like two
or three and they put them in a little
fucking baggies here,
you know?
But this actually had the fucking cigar
box with the little nail in it and shit.
But what sucks is over
there they have like,
they put these warning labels that
are just beyond warning labels.
Like the first one I look,
hey,
I'll bump bumper stick APP is they say
bumper sticker across the fucking top of
it.
Okay.
And it was a picture of
a guy's cancerous mouth,
like lesions on his lips and like he
had all kinds of periodontal issues and
fucking write it out teeth. It's
like, I don't need to see that.
Okay.
When I buy a case of beer,
they don't show a picture of a fucking,
how'd he say there was cirrhosis, liver
cirrhosis sized cirrhosis of the liver,
liver cirrhosis scenes. What do they
not show me a fucking picture of that.
Some fatty fucking liver they don't.
So I actually had to go between the
lesser of two evils and other one had like
literally the skull and bones with some
sort of like not a graduated cylinder.
The one that Kinda looks like a beer mug,
but there's no handle on it.
All you nerds out there, I know
what the fuck it is. Right? Um,
they had that on there.
That was like the best I could fucking do.
And I brought it back to the country and
okay,
I dunno, I've kind of picked up a
cigar habit. I have to break it.
So now I got fucking, I got 24
left and someone was like, dude,
you got to get a human door.
He can't let those things go bad.
So now I bought a humidor.
So now I'm a fucking smoker.
I guess I can't give into this habit.
I just bought a fucking is a humidor.
So we call it, they teach
me all the fuck off. Fuck.
I was supposed to put this scars today.
Now that they seasoned it.
Oh Gee, she, what the
Fuck's wrong with me?
How bored are you that you start
smoking cigars? At 44 I'm a dumb cunt.
Um, oh, so I didn't get
back to the fucking,
the horror talking about the robots.
Yeah.
All right. So she starts to speech, right?
Not a whore, just dressed like a whore.
Like she put on half of our call and Wean
Costa when then to, Oh wait a minute,
I have to give a speech. So she
goes down there and she's just like,
she actually sounds,
what she's talking about is smart,
but she doesn't sound that smart.
So I don't know if some nerd wrote the
fucking speech for and got like, I dunno
fucking broke out in hives right before
the speech. So they sent her out instead,
but she's just sucked everything.
Like you know what,
I was allowed Darl I remember just seeing
star wars and seeing c three Po going,
wouldn't that just be awesome to
have like a robot and that's it.
Like do jobs that just to like kind
of talk to and like joke around with.
And she starts talking about how she
feels that robots should be in the fucking
house because she wants
her own [inaudible].
Oh my saying that right. Am I pausing at
the wrong time? I go into the three Po
c three Po c three P O or whatever.
There's such a stupid fucking movie
because one of the most overrated fucking
Gad, damn motherfucking movies, a vault.
I would rather watch
muppets take Manhattan.
I think that that holds up better because
at least there's adult humor in there.
You know, you know, totally
ripped off. Use the force.
Joel Olsteen,
they'd fucking squinty dad gay when
you were in a tee shirt cheese.
Won't she a have a key here? Just
think about it. It's going to happen.
He totally stole that whole vibe.
I don't even know if that makes sense.
So you're not, furthermore, I don't care.
Plowing ahead to this lady sitting there,
lady sitting there talking
about these fucking robots.
You got to watch the video and about,
I don't know, 10 11 minutes in,
I can't remember where the fuck it is.
They cut to somebody shooting the shit
with a robot and it looks like it's
basically a head coming out of a giant VCR
and he's like sitting there like,
it's be like if you had a VCR,
their head coming out of it,
but like a robot head like
bolts for eyes and shit,
but it has like eyelashes for
some stupid reason, like blinking,
like it needs to blink.
Right.
And he's sitting at it
like he's at his desk,
like almost face to face with the thing.
He's just like,
Hey fucking r two d two look up.
My girlfriend bought me and he
showed some sort of fucking,
I dunno what the hell.
At some macho chain of a watch.
I can't remember what the fuck it was.
And then the robots just like, oh my God,
that's real. A actress thing, dead shape
and it's movement. It's fucking head.
Can I ask,
okay.
Either this might be the dumbest
question ever or just painfully obvious.
Why the fuck would I need that?
Well, why would I need that?
Like why?
Why won't I just talked to my friend?
You know what I'm saying? It's like the
baseball kid from way back in the day.
Remember that shit? I talked about it
here on the podcast. One of these Mondays,
they have the baseball kid. It's
called baseball kid, the baseball kid.
A baseball's work. You won't
to do baseball, kibble, Phd,
and it was a cardboard cutout of a friend
basically that you don't have throwing
a fucking baseball to you. You know? It
was basically for the kid with no friends.
So now they've upgraded it to the
person who has no fucking friends.
You. What's great is that I bet that
guy didn't even have a girlfriend.
I bet he bought the watch for himself
and now he's now part of the sickness is
he just fucking lies to this robot
about this life that he doesn't have.
And you know, once you start
doing that, it's an inevitable,
it's an inevitability.
It's a fucking a cirrhosis of the liver
that that guy's eventually going to
stick his fucking human dick and that
robot mouth and the second that fucking
happens, that's it. It's the
end of the fucking human race.
I'll tell you right now,
this fucking,
this scientist out there
fucking robots right now,
they're out there banging robots,
you know,
under the whole platform
of fucking research.
It's really scary.
Like go go watch this shit on ted.com.
They got another one showing
how we're fighting wars now.
And like these guys sit in Arizona,
they go to basically go to work,
they go to war and then they come home
after fucking blowing up some bad guys.
Uh, hopefully bad guys, right?
And then they fucking go and they sit
down and hang out with their kids and
they're sitting there talking
about how, uh, you know,
now the bad guys are getting the
robots and blah blah. It's just,
it's fucking inevitable.
All those drones that basically,
eventually all this shit,
they use it over there.
I think eventually they're going
to use over here. You know,
in the future there'll be
no more skipping jury duty.
The second you skip it,
you're going to wake up in the morning,
peek out the window, and there's going to
be a fucking drone just hovering there.
You have seven minutes to get to
court or you will be vaporized.
It's going to be one of
those fucking things.
Is this the least interesting
thing you ever heard in your life?
I mean it didn't. I just basically
do every science fiction movie.
Has there ever been a science fiction
movie where they predict something great?
That's what I'm going to do.
I want to be original here for once in
my fucking life. Let's go the other way.
It's going to be a friendly drown.
It's going to be outside that window.
Go back to sleep.
It's okay.
We set your cloud to go
down to the Jerry Dory
hit now we don't need you
so you will be vaporized.
You will be vaporized. That's the
way to do it. I think that that's,
that's going to be the,
the the,
that's going to be the funeral in 2020
I think by 2020 we're going to know
definitely where you go when you die
and if it's anywhere other than here,
people are just going to
choose to tap out. You know?
It's going to be like getting a vasectomy.
Just getting fucking vaporized.
Still an intense fucking procedure that
that needs a serious talking before you
do it. But you know. Yeah. You know,
I'm just getting set, need to change.
You know,
like when people on the east coast moved
to like Minnesota or fucking San Diego
just needed a change.
That's what's going to happen.
People just going to get vaporized
here in the future. It's fucking true.
You know? I know you guys are
rolling your eyes right now,
but you don't have access to
the information that I do. Okay.
So please reserve your
judgment or whatever, whatever.
Temper your judgment.
Don't be hasty with you.
Just whatever that fucking expression is.
MMM.
Are you know what though?
You know what the,
one of the dumbest things I fucking
did in the 80s is I never watch talking
heads. Stop making sense.
That concert movie,
I finally for some fucking reason sat
down and watched it. Why did I watch? Oh,
I know.
I watched it because this,
there was this song that
was in a lot of movies,
like risky business in
those coming of age movies,
all the movies that I saw when I first
got cable and first went to the movies.
And, uh, no, at first when I first
got cable and I went to the movies,
oh Geesh.
And uh,
whenever there was a party going on and
they wanted to show everybody go nuts,
like three or four of those
movies played this song where the,
there was like no lyrics.
The song just went
hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hey.
Hi.
And the whole fucking
place was going nuts.
That's just a great song to sing
when you're drunk. The whole house.
Aye.
And I never knew what the song was,
so it was just in my fucking head going,
what the fuck was that song that was
played, that song and that song? Oh yeah.
By yellow. Um, that, Ooh, I remember that.
Which I always felt someone should
have done a remix of me saying,
oh Jesus to that I would do it,
but then I'd have some sort of fucking
copyright infringement and because I have
advertising on here at some point some
point somebody's going to try to come at
me and get a couple of
nickels. Right. But anyway,
so I finally looked up that song.
I just wrote googled song.
Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. That's all
I did. And then I looked it up.
Find out what's a talking
heads song called swamp.
And then that led me to youtube
next Sinoma I'll stop making sense.
And I watched just that clip of it. Just
watched that, that song go on Youtube,
that's youtube video the week
talking heads. Stop making sense.
Swamp.
Just watch how that fucking thing is shot
and go back and watch the beginning of
the concert. How they come out is one
of the coolest fucking things I've seen.
And to think that there was that quality
of music going on and the shit that I
was fucking listening to, Ya know?
And I'm not saying it's all shit.
I actually owe appetite for destruction
and apology because I went back and
actually that was another
one that I watched when they
were alive at the fucking
rights and I'm like,
I'm an asshole.
I judge that album because I watched
some shit, fucking quiet riot video,
whatever. That's that's how you do comedy.
You just, you just speak in absolutes.
Then you piss people off. If
I, it was actually even handed,
no one would fucking listen
to this. Right. But anyways,
that's one of the dumbest things
I did in the eighties is uh,
I remember when it came out
and Siskel and Ebert were,
were like freaking out saying this is
like the best fucking concert movie I've
seen in a decade and Yada Yada
Yada and all this type of shit.
And I was just like, cause the only
thing I knew was burning down the house.
I'm like,
Oh that weird guy with the white lines
going through his head on the road at the
end of it. Watch out. Um,
all right,
Delta curing breast cancer bill.
I just got an email from
delta sky miles with
my monthly up account update all
the texts and links were pink.
Thank Christ at Delta is finally putting
forth a serious effort towards fighting
breast cancer.
Yeah.
Isn't it weird that you can
actually get angry at a fucking,
okay.
Something so good.
Yeah.
Never underestimate overexposure.
You know what that pink shit is right now.
It's Ben Affleck when he
was dating Jennifer Lopez.
Remember that point and then all of a
sudden the red sox were doing well and
they'd be in the playoffs and then he'd
be sitting right next to the dugout and
you're like, oh my God, if I see
this guy one more fucking time,
that's what life dealt that.
That pink ribbon shit is
okay.
Fucking eye on. Unbelievable.
This is just, it's just, you know,
I got it. I'm aware. You
know, who do I give to?
Let's fucking curate. Okay. Letting,
letting get Gulf right. All right.
Divorce Law. Fucking army, dude.
That's what this next one's called.
Hey Bill.
My name is John A and I'm an
active active duty military.
Okay.
Is that, is that how you say it? Like he's
good police. I am active duty military.
Uh,
I just listened to your comments about
divorce laws and how the wife gets half
of the money and I felt compelled
to write you about my situation. No,
I'm saying whoever is
making more money part,
if it makes more money gets fucked in
the divorce because Brittany Spears got
fucked. All right. That's my
point. And generally speaking,
the guy makes more money,
which I'm not allowed to say some
reason I guess that's sexist,
but women can bitch about it all the time.
How can they do?
But if I actually acknowledge it,
it's, it's just one of those deals.
I'm not allowed to say,
well, I can say it,
but then I have to listen
to people bitch at me. Um,
I currently serve in the U s army.
I recently filed for divorce
in North Caca Lackey,
North Carolina from my wife
because she wasn't working.
This guy's definitely military
getting right to the point. Uh,
we were only married a year and a half.
As soon as she walked out the door,
I had to pay or $820 a month for a year.
Uh,
the army told me it was mandatory.
So on top of paying her her that shit,
I now have to cover my mortgage. I
have served in Afghanistan, Germany,
Romania,
and even state side for this country.
And because my ex wife
decided to walk out,
I was entitled to pay her $820 a month.
Isn't that unbelievable? Why is
that? You don't have any kids.
She's an adult. Go get a fucking job
anyways. The whole time we were married,
she didn't have a job. Well there you go.
I provided everything, paid the bills,
took her to nice places, bought her
a dog, put a roof over our heads.
I guess what I'm trying to is that I
support your cause to find justification
for this shit. Um, yeah. Did,
did the two biggest things that bug me
are our divorce settlements where the
person who makes more money has to
fucking just pay for the other person.
Like they don't have two arms,
the legs and fucking brains to
arm two arms or legs. That's,
yeah, I did just say that.
That's bugging me. And um,
and all these pass interference
calls in the NHL, Nhl, the NFL,
Jesus, Oh gee. Um,
this is how bad the calls are on the
NFL or how lopsided that shit is.
I'm watching the Patriots today
and even when we're on offense,
the second as a flag and the secondary,
even if I don't see the play, I just go,
I'll give me a fucking break.
I thought that, I thought that that
that fucking corner that got three, uh,
pass interference calls.
I thought one of them,
one of them, the one
where you just, you know,
it was literally Yank and on his fucking
Jersey and other that when he's just
yanking on it a little bit.
That's football.
All right. I know I've talked
about it too much anyway.
And on top of having a stressful job,
I now go home and try to
scrape up money just to put,
just to put gas in the tank of the car.
But she is because she is taking money
that she hasn't done shit to earn.
I'm paying for her apartment so that she
can get banged and it probably and I to
get banged in it probably and live
a simple free life. It's bullshit.
Uh, well bill, I hope to hear back
from you and I appreciate your work.
Yeah, it is bullshit. But you
know what? You got off easy.
You only got a year of that. I just
wish I was a judge and it just be like,
Hey lady. Yeah, as far as I can tell
you a healthy go get a fucking job.
And I could see if she took a year off
from work and she's at home, you know,
washing your fucking undies and that
type of thing and you gotta you gotta
support her until she gets a fucking
job. Couple, two or three months.
What a world,
what a world to live in.
What do you do all day? Because he said
somebody as somebody who listens to this,
has to be in that situation.
All right? You don't have to leave your
name. You don't have to leave your number.
I just want to hear from you.
What is that like to just sit in a fucking
house that you don't have to pay for?
Is it kind of scary
cause you gotta be like,
well what if he stops paying then I'm out
of my ass. What if he decides, Fuck you,
I'm going to jail.
He or she,
you know,
do you ever just sit there and just
like not get up one day and just,
just going to sit in bed and eat fruit
loops all day? Why not? I can do it,
you know?
And then do you ever watch like Oprah and
see people doing shit with their lives
and get that sort of weird
feeling in your head like, hey,
shouldn't I do something with my life?
Yeah.
Instead of fucking sucking the
life out of another human being,
the honestly I would love to hear
from you. What do you do all day?
Do you get enjoyment out of that?
Going to the mall,
walking around where
everybody else's at work.
Can you just sit there and walking around
trying to find another pair of horse
shoes before you walk into a cheesecake
factory. I'll just have a salad.
All right.
So you can track to another deck in your
life that can pay for another couple of
years.
That's the game plan that's going to get
you to the playoffs. I don't think so.
Play offs. You kidding
me? Playoffs. Uh, alright.
Skeletons in our Facebook.
Hey Billy boy.
I'm a big fan and new
listener. Thank you. Ah,
[inaudible] I am in a
little bit of a predicament.
I got onto my laptop the other day when
I woke up around one in the afternoon.
I worked the night shift.
I looked through my history and I see
some fucked up conversations that my
girlfriend is having on
Facebook with another guy.
Oh,
Dj.
Uh, they were old emails, but
it was obvious that she would,
she's still thinking about this guy.
Wait a minute,
I've got to go back and do the math on
this. I got into the laptop the other day.
I woke up around one in the
afternoon and worked the night shift.
I looked through my history and I see
some fucked up conversations that my
girlfriend is having on Facebook with
another guy. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
You're on your laptop,
dude.
Fuck all this shit.
Just be honest.
You got a weird vibe off your
girlfriend or your fucking,
you don't trust. You don't trust her
or you don't trust people in general
and you went on her Facebook account.
Okay?
Isn't that what you did?
Okay.
Now we're caught up here.
They were old emails,
but it's obvious that she's
still thinking about this guy.
How was it still obvious
if they're old emails,
if she hasn't emailed the
guy since she got with you?
Okay.
She says, the one that caught me
was from around two years ago.
It said something about having
a sleep over with this guy.
The only problem is that we
were dating at the time. Uh Oh.
Then a few months later, she emails
him again saying she misses him.
What the fuck? I've been nothing but good
to this girl. That doesn't mean Shit,
dude. If our hearts with this other
guy, uh, she lives in my house,
doesn't pay bills or even tries or
even tries to keep food in the house.
I'm always the one keeping the house
straight. I'm the one who does everything.
I'm too nice a guy.
I guess everything I say,
she freaks out and starts to cry and shit.
I been with her for almost three years.
I don't know what to do.
Should I confront her about the other guy?
I was kind of snooping on her shit
when I found this stuff. There it is.
There it is. Yeah. Dude. You know what?
You know why you're snooping and you
knew what you were going to find that you
didn't want to find.
You probably had one eye closed cause
you knew what you were going to find and
you found it. Anyways. He goes,
I mean, don't get me wrong.
She snooped on my Facebook too at times
and caught me talking to other girls,
but all my life I've never
been unfaithful to her.
And this kid that she used to know looks
like slots from the Goonies fucked up
brother. Any advice would be great.
Yeah. You guys, what are you doing?
You're just calling it to each
other. Break up. Ah, yeah.
Yeah.
What are you doing? All
right. First of all,
I don't believe that you've
never been unfaithful to her.
I don't believe that because it took
your fucking two paragraphs to admit that
you actually went into her
fucking Facebook. So I'd be,
I think if this email was another
two paragraphs would be like,
except this one time when I let this
girl blow me 12 fucking times on seven
different dates, you know? Um,
okay.
I Dunno. First of all, forget the
fact that she's fucking around or,
or whether or not she's fucking around
or whether she has feelings with somebody
else. How can you be in a relationship
with somebody that every time you bring
something up,
I want to talk to about something heavy.
She freaks out and cries about
it. She's not an adult, you know,
she's a child. She's acting
like a little kid. All right?
There's no reason to fucking
cry when you're an adult.
There's no reason to
fucking cry unless somebody,
something tragic has happened to
somebody you love. Other than that,
if I'm bringing up the fact
that I feel like you, you know,
you haven't done the dishes as many
times have, I've done it lately or a,
you know,
I go to bed earlier than you do when
you come into bed with your fucking iPad
and it's lightened up the goddamn room,
like a flying saucers coming down and
you have a little consideration. This,
if you start crying during that,
you're an asshole.
All right?
You're a fucking child.
You know what he should do?
He should just get a fucking pacifier.
That's what I would do.
Yeah.
The next time you go to bring
something up, she starts crying.
You just pull it out and be like,
okay,
Ooh.
And you wave it in her face and you just
throw it against the wall and you go,
Yep,
yeah. Fucking baby. All right.
Right,
right there.
You're not going to have to worry about
what to do when the relationship because
it's going to be all
okay.
Uh,
my right plowing ahead.
What do we got here? Any more advertising,
amazon.com you know what to dope.
You want to donate to this podcast and
then now also be dealt donating to the
troops, which I have not sent
them a check in like two months.
I got to send them a fatty.
Yeah,
whatever.
Been on the road for fucking
seven weeks.
Just being honest.
I got to send them or else the fucking
piano is going to fall on my head. Uh,
just go to [inaudible] dot
com click on the podcast page,
click on the Amazon link.
Go ahead and buy something if you want
and they'll kick me a little something.
It doesn't cost you anything extra,
and then I kicked something
through the fucking troops,
which I'm overdue on doing,
which I'm going to do. All right.
gamefly.com you know you
want 8,000 games at your,
your fingertips for 15
day free fucking trial.
Go to www dot [inaudible] game
fly.com/bill burp baby. No,
not baby www.game.
fly.com/bill burr,
two weeks of video games and
then you got it and it's over.
Then your life is great. All
right. From a lady in the lab,
I'm a lady in my late twenties.
I'm very lucky because I'm happily
married and I'm getting a phd at a large
research institution. My Phd, uh,
is mostly paid for by the university
in exchange for working as a research
assistant under a professor
in my department. Uh,
that sounds like the beginning of a porno.
Uh,
my tuition is greatly reduced and
I pay for my education with cash.
It's a good deal. Good for
you. See person before,
this is the kind of girl you
want to be with right here.
Although you kind of seem
like you got some issues too.
You got to work out your own issues
before you deserve a lady like this.
A lady in the lab,
she's got that white coat
and those smart glasses,
she looks like a nerd.
And one day you'd take out your cock,
she undoes her hair, takes off the
glasses, does that fucking flip.
And next thing you know you're having
a kid that's called the lady in the lab
love Song. Um, here's my problem.
I work on a large large research
team with several other students,
one of whom is a much older man.
I know this is going to go into
sexual direction at some point.
Is he some dirty pervert fucking
hair coming out of his ears? Um,
anyways, he's probably in his late
fifties, early sixties. I am regularly.
And why is he doing this so late in life?
Cause he probably has some fear
of commitment. I'm telling you.
He's taken his dick out. I'm calling
it right now. Paul Versey moment.
He takes his fucking Dick out by the end
of this story. All right, here we go.
I'm regularly assigned to work with
him and he always treats me like uh,
like gum stuck to the bottom of his
shoe. Yeah, he's breaking it down.
His Treatment of me varies from
inpatient to crew, but there's never any,
never any evidence of his
meanness or an email trail of it.
He's too careful for that
up. All right. I was wrong.
He's just a mean son of a bitch.
My method for at least the last three
years was to kill them with kindness.
It has never worked.
I tried to be a few Civ,
I don't even know what that
means and personable and sweet,
but the only response I get from him,
his disdain I've given up on this method
now because it makes me feel like a
doormat. Yeah, absolutely.
And frankly, I'm too angry.
I only speak to him when I'm required
to and I've been trying to keep my head
down and graduate and get out soon.
I will be moving on and out too.
I'll be moving on and out
of the research team, but I,
but I hate to think about
what my replacement faces.
She's a lovely person and she's already
noted how mean this guy is to me and
she's confided that he
has been rude to her too.
I feel so angry that I can't
help or protect her in any way.
She even said to me, I would just
try to kill them with kindness. Oh,
I'll just try to kill them with kindness.
Hear her saying that. Broke my heart.
I know it won't work.
Why can't you just say to the guy,
hey, just out of curiosity,
it's been, I've been with
you for three years and you,
you're one of the meanest human
beings I've ever met in my life is,
is there a reason for this?
You know,
do I have halitosis do I remind you of
some woman that took you for all you got
and divorce court?
What exactly is your problem?
You old can't leave out
the last part. Um, anyways,
she says, I don't want to complain about
him to any higher up in our department.
I'm certain no administrator would listen
to me or care and I'd only make myself
look like a whiner. Yeah, I don't,
you, you, you know what it is.
You know why you've sat here for three
years taking shit from this guy cause
you're, you're putting no value on
yourself. No one's going to listen to me.
No one wants to hear it. They'll
just think I'm a whiner. Um,
I think in a very nice way,
if you haven't been a jerk to anybody
and you've been there for three years,
you've never demonstrated
any sort of poor behavior.
Why wouldn't they listen to you?
Like that's all Becky.
Kill them with Karen. Kill them with
kindness. Oh my God. If she's complaining,
something's gotta be wrong with
this guy. Right. Anyway, she says,
and while I know he's a bastard
to all of all of our other peers,
the younger students and the secretary,
he's a kiss ass to the director
and other tenured professors.
Is this a real person or a cartoon?
This sounds like the asshole fucking
boyfriend of the hot chicken every coming
of age movie, you know, the hot Chicco
eventually ends up with the nerd,
which never happens in real life.
Not until your thirties. Um,
lodging a formal complaint wouldn't
resonate with anyone who has the power to
fix the situation.
Okay.
On the other hand,
I want to tell this guy off,
or the very least let him know that
he can't bully people like this.
He's a mean fat, miserable. Fuck.
You really are angry. I love it.
Who has made my professional life hell
and I want him to know exactly what I
think of him. How do you think I show go
about this without getting into trouble?
Uh,
by the way,
even though this man has a semipermanent
position in our department,
I still have more graduate
degrees than he does,
even though I'm probably
half his age feels good. Um,
all right. You know what?
You're almost graduating.
You saying, you know, this guy's a kiss
ass. It's not going to do anything.
I think this calls for
a good practical joke.
Just make his life a living hell.
I know in the past I said,
don't fuck with somebody's car, but
this might be the perfect time to do it.
You know, it's a good thing to do. Go to
mcdonalds. This just, this is what you do.
You just make his life a living hell.
Just go to Mcdonald's or to
some French fries and say, Hey,
can I get a couple of weeks to those
ketchup packs, you know, thank you.
And then you just go out to his car and
you'd take the ketchup and you put it
underneath this door handle.
Just a little country, things
like that. And then need,
just stay on the other
side of the parking lot.
And you giggle as you watch this miserable
motherfucker walking over to the car.
Can you please do this and send a video
so I can show it to all my listeners and
listeners if you have other logis
little nothing where he gets hurt.
Just little messes that he
has to keep cleaning up.
You know, just put a little bit
of catchup underneath there.
And I actually did that to someone
one time and I swear to God,
by the time the person got to the car,
I was in the exact same situation.
By the time the person got to the car,
I was laughing so hard.
I almost passed out. Just the
anticipation of this fucking cunt.
You know who I was basically in the
same situation you were in, you know,
just do that. It's, it's
fucking hilarious. Um,
and then the next time he goes
out to his car, he's going to,
he's going to have to like,
you know,
do it with one finger to just see
if there's anything underneath it.
Just do shit like that. What else can you
do? I need to know more about this guy.
All right. Where does he
live? What does he do?
I would even go old school now. He
probably know the, the, the, the,
you take a shit in a bag,
ring the doorbell.
You light it on fire and then the guy
comes out and stomped it out and steps on
shit. That's one of the oldest ones
in the book. I would just do two silly
to our,
just too silly shit like that to them.
Just something that's gonna make you
laugh, get it on video and send it to me.
We'll put it up on the fucking Internet,
but then you'll get in trouble.
I don't know, Dude. I don't
know what to tell you.
If you're not going to go to your
higher ups or confront this guy,
I don't know how other way you're going
to get this person back other than to
just do little fucking silly
things like that. I Dunno.
I feel like I let you down,
but you kind of walled me off.
Why don't you take off your smart glasses
and undo the fucking bar at and your
hair, shake it out and just be like,
can I have a word with you? You know,
talk to the higher ups like that. Use
the power of sex. I'm the fucking worst.
Why do you guys ask me advice?
Is it because you want me to realize
how dumb I am? Cause if that's the,
if that's the end game here, it's working
a bill. How to find a chick like Nia.
Ah, isn't that nice? Hi Bill. I was
listening to some of your podcasts, Nia,
and it just hit
me how much both of you are so fucking
aware of what's going on underneath
whatever the fuck you are rambling on
about at the moment. No. What I mean?
Uh, sort of, she knows what you're talk,
she knows when you're talking out your
ass or acting like an idiot and she plays
with it.
She seems to understand just like you
understand that when someone says bitches
ain't shit, it probably just means that
the guy is afraid of commitment. Oh, okay.
I see what you're saying. And he goes,
I'm talking about the Greek Green Room,
the green room episode where you get
in an argument with that lady and you
quickly talk about that. Um, anyway, shit,
that seems so fucking obvious to some,
especially Comedians,
uh, yet it never yet never even
considered by the majority of people.
Ah, no, that's not really a
comedian thing. That's just,
I took a psychology class.
We really wish I could take credit for
the fact that I can make fun of somebody
big head,
that I somehow understand their childhood.
Now that that's like psych one on one,
but I'll take the credit if
you'll give it to me anyways,
my question is how the fuck
do you meet a girl like that?
I'm 29 and although I
know I'm still young,
I can't figure out how the fuck to meet
someone who's not some other clueless
fucking cunt waiting for some Douche
bag to make them feel better about them.
Days is okay. I'm, before you even go
through the rest of that tirade, dude,
you know what it is. You keep fucking
drop an anchor in the same poison Pont.
All right? You keep fishing
in the same water and haul.
You keep making meeting the same fucking
girl. I'm not going to lie to you.
It took a while to meet a girl
like Nia, but like a, you know,
I did keep meeting the same types of
women over and over and over and over and
over again cause I kept going
to like meet market bars.
Where would I always meet women? I
mean, I always met women at the gym.
You know,
I don't know how.
I always say how I always,
I always had game at the gym and I sucked.
I sucked in the meat market.
I was the fucking worst. The, at the,
the few times I tried
to go to the dance club,
nobody wants a fucking pasty freckled
face jackass screaming over usher in their
ear. They just don't
want it. They don't want,
I didn't have any fucking luck over that.
But you get me in a Goddamn gym and
you've got survivor on the fucking goddamn
speaker. I, I got a little game.
Not a lot, but I got a little, the gym,
the gym is a great place to meet a psycho,
you know what I mean?
Either somebody who has an unbelievable
body issues or then you get the married
chick who's, who's fucking not
happy in a relationship. You know,
she's going to the gym dressed in these
ridiculous fucking outfits. You know,
those fucking hoary outfits.
So like,
do you really need to have that
much fuck that little clothing on?
You know,
I do. They're always doing
those bend over, you know,
those fucking chicks that actually go
in the weight room but don't really lift
weights.
You know,
they're always working on their
fucking ham strings or whatever.
I don't know.
I'm sure there's the guy version of that.
But I don't pay attention to it.
Right.
The big creepy guy walking around with
this fucking half a ball hanging out,
hanging around the fucking,
I was going to say lunch room.
There's no lunch from there.
Is there,
I guess there were always is that little
area with the fucking power bars. Um,
here's funny,
they actually did a story on the local
news out here about how those energy
drinks that they have
actually have surprisingly,
if not dangerously high levels of
caffeine. Isn't that a stunner?
Can you believe that?
Isn't that unbelievable?
That you could sit there and be like,
oh my God, I need 10 hours of sleep.
Take a fucking drink of this shit
and be like, oh no, wait a minute.
I think I'll go paint the house.
You know,
you don't think that there's something
in there. If it's not caffeine,
it's basically liquid coke. You know, I,
uh, you know, I know somebody who I am
convinced they were fucking overweight,
but I'm convinced that, uh, it's not,
it's not who you think it is.
Somebody outside of the fucking comedy
world was drinking those fucking five
hour energy things.
From what I heard,
like they were going out of style.
This fucking things that, that crazy.
Can I actually say that they were
allegedly right, allegedly. Crazy.
Crazy. He, they're fucking
crazy for feeling so low.
Um, I think that's a podcast for this
week. Everybody. I gradually sobered up,
gradually worked off the buzz.
I hope you enjoyed it as much as I did.
Um, the fucking, you know,
it's funny about the jets.
The jets don't try against anybody in
the AFC east unless they're playing the
patriots. Well, they play the
Patriots. They just fucking show up.
Anytime I see him play the
dolphins, they're just like, eh,
it's just the dolphins.
Fuck it. Hoses the bills.
Uh, get over here yet. Fucking
knucklehead. Maybe that's just me.
Okay.
Probably is right.
Is there anything else that
I wanted to talk about? Hey,
can you explain to me how a fucking
king snake can fucking eat a rattlesnake
when the rattlesnake clearly
looks like it's biting it?
Evidently it has some sort of like,
yeah,
a little bit of immunity to the poisoned
unless it gets bit in the fucking head.
But then I went on
youtube and I was looking,
I was trying to find a sanction loss
between a king snake in a fucking
rattlesnake.
Do you believe the level of free time I
have in my life that this is something
that I actually do? I imagine a lot
of you guys do it too. Um, all right.
Youtube king snake. There's a sick one
of like a cotton mouth eating a fucking,
I always root for the animals.
That's, and I hate fucking snakes.
And when I see what snake
attack another snake,
I actually start to feel bad
for the snake that's dying.
It doesn't make any oh king be John
Belushi. You guys ever see this?
Did you guys ever see that?
That clip from SNL?
I'll fucking tight as a band
that's playing with them.
That drummer is insane on that. I can't,
does anybody know who the drummer is on?
It's an SNL one. I'll bill.
Who gives a shit? All right,
that's the podcast for this
week. Listen, listen to me.
I'm going to be in a knowledge, listen
to this shit. This is my weekend.
I want to be in New Orleans
this weekend at a casino.
Let me see if I can get
you the actual shows.
Harris in new,
a New Orleans Harris
Casino in New Orleans,
Louisiana.
I got two shows Friday night show time,
7:00 PM and 9:00 PM and I'm
going to be with New Jersey Zone.
Paul Dude, I called it Versie.
It's going to be great.
It's going to be great. Oh, by the way,
just to warn you, I shaved my beard off.
Just am I going to be,
I'm gonna look like I did when I did
let it go except not as fucking booze
headed.
So Friday night I'm
doing that show and then
as they say in Boston,
Saturday sachet or you're really
Bostonian, if you don't even know.
It's just all vowels between the s
and the why. Why aren't you come over,
come over on Saturday.
Um,
Saturday I am going to
the fucking Lsu Alabama
fucking SCC football game. That
was one of my bucket list. I said,
one of these days, I'm got one
of these days, I'm going to what?
That l a to an Lsu home game
and it's finally happening.
This is my little bucket list thing.
So if this is my last Monday, no,
that I died doing what I wanted to do.
Um,
you know it's funny as I actually do die
between this Monday and another Monday,
do you understand the amount of Douche
bags who believe in wizardry and all
that's going to be like,
do you know why he died?
He died because he said he
would get a day. Rarely.
Then all I have to say is this time
next week I will be worth $100 million.
Now see that doesn't work because that's
something good. Oh go fuck yourself.
And um, and then on Sunday I'm
just fucking hanging around.
I'm not doing nothing other than going
down Bourbon street, getting drunk,
seeing some titties and trying
not to get stabbed. Okay.
Cause that's what Bourbon Street,
Bourbon Street.
Basically when you get on Bourbon Street,
you stay on Bourbon Street.
Do not make a right. Do not
make a left. Do not pass go.
You stay on Bourbon on Bourbon Street.
You are within the herd.
You make a right. Uh,
you make a left and you are that lonely
zebra drinking at the watering hole out
on the fucking Serengeti.
And there's somethings gonna reach up
and grab you and they're going to find,
you know,
your foot's going to be used in some sort
of Voodoo fucking ceremony. All right?
And that's New Orleans.
That's New Orleans.
Stay on Bourbon Street. Oh,
tourist. But Friends of mine.
Um, and I'm hanging around.
Why? Cause Monday Bop Bop, bop,
bop. Boda Boda do, I'm
going to the Monday thing.
Such a Douche. I've gone to a, the
Sates Eagles game on Monday night. See,
that's what I'm doing. All you guys,
you got married, had kids and go,
I gotta go buy a new rake. Why'd you
do it? I know cause it's awesome,
right? You get to dress him up this
time a year. What are you going on?
I want to go out. Is this all right?
We'll get you a little fucking mask.
Do you know I haven't made my
pumpkin bread yet? Cleo. Cleo,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
You've been itching like a goddamn maniac.
Do I have to give you a bath?
Does anybody know the dogs?
How are you?
I love you too.
The dogs like I know they don't,
my dog does not like getting a bath,
but to do,
do they feel better after a bath?
Okay.
I can't tell if it's flipping out
because it feels good or it's absolutely
ecstatic that it's over.
This dog goes absolutely ballistic.
The second it's over, you dry it
off and then it just sits there.
It's almost like it literally
has a fucking smile on its face.
That's my dog question. Um, all right,
so that's the podcast this week.
Youtube videos of the week. Once again
are, we'll have the links to them. Um,
is that that Ted robot video,
the talking heads swamp.
Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi. Hi
fucking clip from stop
making sense. Swamp. And uh,
and please give that woman just some
fucking practical joke shits you can do.
Why don't you just go old
school and literally put a
bucket of water over a door
and just get them totally
like three stooges style,
you know?
Is there a way to make somebody feel you
can't make them fall down the stairs?
That's bad.
Would it be great if he did? All right.
That's the podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week. Um,
my condolences to the Ryan family,
the one on the jets and the cowboys.
I still can't believe the
fucking giants won that game.
Those fucking God damn Lucky Kahn's great
football team. But Jesus, what is it?
When is there luck going to run out?
Touchdown.
I have to further Rubio.
Unbelievable. What was it like?
Just the side of his pinky was out
of bounds. Unfucking believable.
When is Tony Romo going to have some
luck? All right, that's it. See you.